bonsoir l'europe s'accroche à l' axe
franco allemand helmut kohl était cet
après midi à paris les marchés
financiers restent très nerveux
bonsoir les autres titres de l'actualité
d'abord la france touchée de plein fouet
par les orages trois morts et un disparu
en ardèche le plan orsec dans le
vaucluse et d'énormes dégâts dans le sud
prison le ministère de la justice
réplique aux maladies diplomatique des
gardiens mécontents et demandent des
contre expertises
enfin le feuilleton maradona s'arrête à
séville c'est en espagne que diego la
star jorat la saison prochaine depuis
hier la france a donc été balayées par
de très violents orages météo france
avait publié plusieurs messages d'alert
des phénomènes localisés avec de très
grosses pluies et du vent et le premier
bilan est lourd trois personnes sont
mortes emportées par les crues de
l'ardèche près d'aubenas une quatrième
est portée disparue dans le vaucluse le
plan orsec a été déclenché et à
vaison-la-romaine un immeuble s'est
effondré il y aurait d'autres victimes
sous les décombres le point sur les
intempéries avec caroline cyence le
luberon cet après-midi noyé sous les
trombes d'eau là comme dans tout le sud
de la france les rues sont inondées les
routes coupées
les maisons saccagées ici dans le lot on
évacue en toute hâte les campings la
violence des orages a surpris tout le
monde
l'ump a lavé les grossistes ou plus
deux mini tornades se sont abattues sur
le sud ouest et le sud est de la france
trois personnes sont mortes en ardèche
emportée par la rivière en crue
quatre autres personnes sont portées
disparues dans ce département et dans la
drôme dans le vaucluse
la situation est catastrophique le plan
orsec a été déclenché ici à
châteaurenard le stade s'est effondré
vaison la romaine est actuellement
coupée du monde un immeuble s'est
écroulé des gens seraient bloquées sous
les décombres
toute la région privés de téléphone
n'est accessible que par la voie des
airs 200 hommes et huit hélicoptères
sont arrivés en renfort pour secourir ce
département les dégâts matériels et
humains causés par ces orages seront
très importants
une dernière information que viennent de
nous transmettre à l'instant nos
confrères de france 3 marseille cinq
personnes auraient trouvé la mort dans
l'effondrement d'un immeuble à
vaison-la-romaine météorage est formel
il y a eu plus de 50000 impact d'orage
aujourd'hui sur la france vous allez les
découvrir sur cette carte dans les
bouches du rhône
on a même assisté à une mini tornade en
quelques heures il est tombé les deux
tiers des pluies normalement enregistrés
dans une année sur tout le sud est de la
france et sur la région rhône alpes la
prudence est encore recommandé dans ces
régions mais michel tour et vous le
confirmera à 20 heures la tendance est à
l'accalmie
tout devrait redevenir normal dans la
nuit météo complète donc à 20h épidémie
dans les prisons les gardiens restent
chez eux et envoie la chancellerie des
certificats médicaux une maladie donc
très diplomatique baptisé déjà vos lots
et ce matin le ministère de la justice a
décidé de contre attaquer le garde des
sceaux demande une contre-expertise
médicale pour les 1750 gardiens
concernés et au ministère de la santé
oms met en garde les médecins trop
complaisant le reportage à chalons sur
marne de france 3 reims michel barthen
une journée de plus devant la porte de
la prison la pluie n'a pas tiédi leur
détermination mais l'amertume gagne du
terrain
hors micro les surveillants de la maison
d'arrêt de châlons se disent écoeurés
mais une fois la caméra branchée plus
personne ne veut en parler ici une
vingtaine de gardiens sont en arrêt
maladie
ils se disent touchés par le syndrome vk
vauzelle karsenti une variante locale de
lavaux élit ce virus inventé par les
syndicats pour protester contre les
sanctions prononcées par le garde des
sceaux ce matin bernard kouchner le
ministre de la santé a protesté contre
la pratique des arrêts maladie prend
vraiment là c'est trop c'est un grand
danger pour la médecine il y aurait d'un
côté et ce serait très grave
parfois ça s'installe déjà d'un côté les
médecins qu'on va voir pour les
certificats et de l'autre médecin qu'on
va voir pour les vraies maladies ça
c'est pas possible
comprenez ce serait vraiment pour la
profession médicale et pour la
déontologie et pour les rapports avec
les malades extrêmement pernicieux
quand on a un patient qui est assis en
face de soi parfois impatients qu'on
connaît bien et depuis longtemps
on ne peut pas en même temps essayer
d'être à l'écouté
des symptômes qu'il va nous fournir pour
faire un diagnostic et en même temps est
en train d'essayer de soupçonner de nous
extorquer quelque chose le ministre de
la justice a ordonné des contre-visites
médicales c'est une pratique courante
dans l'administration en attendant la
surveillance des prisons est toujours
assurée par les forces de l'ordre
quarante huit heures après l'assassinât
d'un gendarme mobile en corse les
enquêteurs tentent par tous les moyens
de trouver les auteurs de ce crime
la levée du corps a eu ce matin sur
l'aéroport d'ajaccio
le ministre de la défense pierre joxe
était présent il a rendu un dernier
hommage à la victime le corps de fabrice
faure a été ensuite rapatriés en
dordogne dans le village de sa famille
où il a été inhumé cet après-midi
remodelage rajout ou aménagement le
petit oui français à maastricht va
sûrement faire évoluer le traité il ne
s'agit pas de le renégocier les douze
ont été très fermes sur ce terme mais
des changements sont actuellement
étudiés c'est le couple franco allemand
qui veut entraîner le reste de l'europe
un couple qui n'a pas tardé à se
retrouver helmut kohl était cet après
midi à paris un premier contact donc
très rapide depuis ce matin on parle
beaucoup d'initiatives et la nouvelle
pourrait venir ce soir d'allemagne une
rencontre au palais de l'elysée suivi
par mémona hintermann c'est un
chancelier un peu raide
le visage figé dans un demi sourire qui
est arrivé à l'elysée de l'après midi un
rendez-vous de près de deux heures avec
le président de la république une
véritable réunion de crise sur l'europe
dans le tangage actuelle cette rencontre
mitterrand kohl était présenté comme le
signal d'une volonté commune des deux
pays pour tenter de redresser la machine
communautaire et puis surprise à la fin
de l'entretien
aucune déclaration aucun communiqué
contrairement à ce qui avait été annoncé
silence total côté français et allemand
dans la situation actuelle il est peu
vraisemblable que ce silence dure car il
permettrait toutes les hypothèses il ne
contribuerait pas à rassurer les marchés
financiers
une hypothèse est retenue ce soir ici
une fois rentré à bonn le chancelier
allemand pourrait annoncer une
initiative une concession de l'allemagne
au nom de la solidarité
elle permettrait de rassurer les marchés
financiers elle serait également
une aide pour le premier ministre
britannique le président de la
communauté qui seraient tentés dit-on
par un ralentissement de l'unification
de l'europe
alors jean marc sylvestre cette
initiative dont on vient de parler à
l'instant et mena lieberman serait
plutôt d'ordre politique
il ya une autre col l'annoncera demain
en arrivant à beaune d'ores et déjà on
peut imaginer bien sûr une nouvelle
baisse des taux d'intérêt allemands si
elle nous te colle peut peser sur le
président de la bundesbank et l'obtenir
mais on sens surtout initiatives d'ordre
politique vis-à-vis de la population
allemande afin d'obtenir un effort de
solidarité notamment une contribution
financière plus importante au
financement et à l' équilibre de
l'europe
alors jean marc si vaste et les marchés
financiers sont tout de même restés très
très nerveux aujourd'hui l'europe
on voit bien va devoir trouver une
solution en gros le lac se reconstitue
autour du franc et du marcat francs qui
d'ailleurs étaient à nouveau attaquées
ou c'est parce qu'il est évident que le
référendum n'a rien réglé le franc se
retrouve aujourd'hui en première ligne
trois raisons la promesse de baisse des
taux d'intérêt en france n'a pas été
tenue encore que là on ne se faisait
guère d'illusion mais nous subissons
aussi le contrecoup du pugilat qui
oppose actuellement la livre sterling
très faible et le mark allemand les
capitaux se tire en allemagne si j'ose
dire et au passage bien ils ratissent la
france enfin l'international se méfie
énormément de l'hexagone intrinsèquement
on considère que le franc est solide
bercy a d'ailleurs dit ce soir qu'il n'y
aurait pas de réaménagement des parités
mais les résultats du référendum ont
aussi montré que la société française
était fissurée et qui sûr et très
gravement coupé en deux et cela les
marchés long je crois découvert à
l'occasion de ce référendum l'obsession
des dirigeants en europe et donc
maintenant de ramener le calme et
surtout la confiance
d'où la visite à paris d'helmut kohl
pour essayer de reconstruire le système
monétaire autour d'une marque et du
front il disait et puis pour prendre des
mesures de relance concertée toute la
question bien sûr est de savoir quelle
interprétation quel accueil aura helmut
kohl en rentrant chez lui et savoir si
l'allemagne est prête à payer les
efforts de solidarité parce que ça
dépend des alors je remarque un dernier
point on a aussi appris aujourd'hui que
le gouver
romance accordé si on peut dire un délai
pour le budget 93 oui alors très
rapidement le budget c'est l'instrument
clé de la politique économique ils
devaient être publiés demain et bien le
gouvernement est complètement dans le
brouillard
les prévisions n'ont jamais été aussi
floue en termes d'activité économique
l'environnement monétaire lui n'a jamais
été aussi dangereux on le voit tous les
jours
enfin la majorité politique pour voter
ce budget n'a jamais été aussi
incertaine
elle n'existe pas alors dans ces
conditions bien on comprend que michel
charasse et pierre bérégovoy et voulu
reprendre leur copie jean-marc crs merci
l'après-référendum maintenant avec la
remise en ordre de certains partis après
le rpr dont nous vous parlions hier soir
ce soir le parti socialiste jean pierre
chevènement n'a plus de bureau
or une seule ferino depuis déjà un
moment mais il devrait rester au parti
socialiste
la décision sera prise demain au comité
directeur du ps et si certains comme
roland dumas ont affiché clairement leur
volonté d'exclure le député maire de
belfort
d'autres au ps souhaite que tous les
courants puissent s'exprimer
même si la critique est parfois vive
daniel sportiello alain thomas
l'impopularité il connaît comme ici au
congrès socialiste de bordeaux
il faut dire que jean pierre chevènement
est encore sorti du rang en disant non à
maastricht par exemple un nom qui n'est
pas qu'européen
il vise la politique du gouvernement
françois mitterrand et à travers le chef
de l'état à certaines exercice du
pouvoir
on se souvient de l'hostilité de
l'ancien ministre de la défense à la
guerre du golfe dernier crime de lèse
majesté en date la création de son
propre mouvement chez lui à belfort et
la menace de présenter ses propres
candidats aux législatives
pourtant laurent fabius a averti
chevènement risque de ne pas avoir
l'investiture du ps
mais le maire de belfort n'est pas
inquiet ils se sont même conforté par le
résultat du référendum
je ne me sens pas désavoué dans le
territoire de belfort le nom citoyen
fusionnant citoyens atteint 54% 55% à
belfort et je vois que partout où la
gauche avait des positions de force
en effet le nom est puissant ça veut
dire quelque chose suivi par 20% de
l'électorat socialiste jean pierre
chevènement est donc un gêneur difficile
à exclure
il est porteur de cette tradition
républicaine et populaire dont le ps ne
peut se passer
à l'heure où le peuple de gauche le
boude jospin rocard poperen sont
d'ailleurs contre l'exclusion et chacun
de se dire au ps que si chevènement veut
partir et bien il n'a qu'à le faire
lui-même
la grande braderie militaire de l'ex
urss un marché où l'on trouve de tout de
la mitraillette à l'avion de chasse en
passant par le porte-avions dernier
exemple des sous marins basés en
lituanie et sur lesquels on a posé un
panneau à vendre aux principaux clients
les pays du proche-orient et ceux du
tiers-monde est en marche du côté
anecdotique de cette affaire certains
s'inquiètent de voir des sous-marins
équipés d'armes sensible vendu presque à
la sauvette
pierre babey 7 et raffin en ce moment
même les flots de la baltique c'est
celle du sous marin russe p r 877
destination le golfe persique
car il vient tout simplement d'être
vendu par la marine russe à la marine
iranienne derniers soldes avant
liquidation
plutôt que de rapatrier ces bâtiments en
russie la marine de boris eltsine les
brade à qui veux les payer 18 millions
de francs à ce prix c'est une aubaine et
les acheteurs se précipitent témoins ces
équipages et leurs familles actuellement
en séjour dans le port de bold et jara
en lituanie nationalité de ses clients
libye cuba algérie syrie irak et iran
déjà nommée évidemment ce père 877 ce
n'est pas octobre rouge
c'est un sous marin classique mais très
moderne
son commandant explique un journaliste
allemand qu'il est équipé d'armes
dernier cri qu'il peut pratiquer la
guerre des mines et le tir de torpille
et qu'il peut combattre aussi bien sous
l'eau quand sur face à face à l'iran qui
organisait ce matin une parade militaire
monstre à téhéran ne peut que se réjouir
de ses emplettes russe ce sous-marin
furent à merveille dans le golfe
arabo-persique tellement heureux de la
sphère les iraniens qu'il vient
d'acheter deux autres sous marins en
soldes l'atlantique ne sera plus la
poubelle nucléaire de l'europe 14 pays
ont signé aujourd'hui une convention il
s'engage à ne plus polluer cet océan ce
sont surtout les français les anglais
qui ont décidé de changer l'attitude
reste maintenant tout même à convaincre
des pays comme les etats unis le japon
ou la russie au reportage de dominique
dumas et philippe basquin après 36
heures de négociations marathon et
malgré quatre heures de retard les 13
pays européens riverains de l'atlantique
nord se sont finalement engagés à ne
plus immergé de déchets radioactifs dans
cette zone
c'est le prolongement naturel de
conventions déjà signées en 74 et 78 à
oslo et paris dans la ligne de la
conférence de l'environnement à rio
l'interdiction est maintenant officiel
cette convention va entraîner certes des
investissements importants pour nos
industriels et pour nos pays mais nous
sommes tous
conscient que lorsque nous faisons des
efforts et lorsque nous renforçons les
normes nous savons précisément bien
anticiper ce type de contraintes
nous pouvons aussi mettre en place une
industrie de l'environnement et
créatrice d'emplois
ces immersions de fûts radioactifs
étaient déjà illicite depuis 82
l'interdiction est maintenant
irréversible sauf pour la france et la
grande bretagne
ces nations nucléaires pourrait
éventuellement remettre en cause leur
engagement individuel dans une quinzaine
d'années il pourrait alors pratiquer de
nouveau des immersions greenpeace qui a
multiplié des actions notamment hier
encore à paris est tout de même confiant
cette interdiction doit durer quinze ans
elle est applicable pour les 13 pays
signataires de la nouvelle convention de
paris nous allons oeuvrer pour que cette
interdiction soit mondial dans les
cadres d'autres conventions et pour
qu'elle soit bien sûr prolongée ou
transformés en interdiction définitive
c'est à dire que pour que l'exception
dont bénéficie la france et l'angleterre
soit levée certes l'europe de
l'environnement a fait un grand pas mais
industriels et défenseurs écologistes
seront obligés de s'entendre et de se
comprendre
paris lille en 1h20 c'est possible le
tgv va desservir le nord de la france et
le 23 mai prochain et la date
d'inauguration a même été avancé après
le sud-est et l'atlantique le nord est
le troisième grand chantier tgv la sncf
lille qui devient une véritable plaque
tournante les tgv filera ensuite vers
l'angleterre la belgique ou la hollande
reportage france 3 lille gilles guillon
et laurence meyer fait
c'est désormais officiel le premier tgv
nord fera son entrée en gare de lille le
23 mai 93 après 1h20 de trajet
paris-lille en une heure ce sera pour
septembre le temps que le nouveau
tronçon au nord d'arras soit terminé les
passagers voyageront à bord d'une rame
comme celle ci un tgv réseau réservé au
trafic intérieur
en 94 de nouvelles rames transmanche
feront leur apparition pour desservir la
grande bretagne si tout va bien
côté français en ce qui concerne le tgv
nord nous sommes à l'heure la ligne aura
été réalisé en 1993 le prolongement vers
bruxelles que auxquels nos amis belges
travaillent activement devrait entrer en
service en 1996
en revanche du côté britannique est un
projet de ligne nouvelle mais pour
lequel pour l'instant il n'y a pas
encore de date de réalisation fixés à
partir de 94 avec la mise en service de
l'interconnexion à l'est de paris lille
sera relié au tgv sud-est puis en 96 ce
sera au tour du tgv atlantique
le tgv nord est sur les rails mais pour
l'instant tout ceci semble encore bien
lointain euralille n'est qu'un vaste
chantier dans huit mois s'élèvera ici la
future plaque tournante du tgv nord
europe
la gare lille-europe soigner le
bégaiement les médecins s'intéressent
enfin à ce handicap c'est ce que montre
cette année les entretiens de bichat une
affection qui touche plutôt les hommes
et qui restent mal connus en tout cinq
cent mille personnes souffrant de
bégaiement les traitements existent ils
sont parfois longs mais efficace pascal
justice et victor arich ont suivi
l'application de ces thérapies le
bégaiement est mal connue il n'existe
aucune étude en france sur ce handicap
pourtant ils touchent pas moins d'un
pour cent de la population fait pire
avec
vidéo g qui a quatre mille ans et qui
veut dire mais gaiement de l'antiquité
égyptienne dont c'est quand même très
très intéressant peut-être que tu l'as
vu non non je n'ai pas vu mais nous
avons fait déjà donc oui parce qu'il ya
4000 ans il y avait des goûts même moïse
était bègue jeunes churchill et louis
jouvet le furent aussi preuve que le
bégaiement ça se soigne à cet exercice
par exemple consiste à aider le patient
à comprendre comment il produit son
bégaiement vous allez il apprend ainsi à
maîtriser les affects qui trouve le son
langage simplement tenez quelle était
votre occupation de ce matin donc mon du
patient de ce matin j'ai dû me lever
relativement tôt
alors je vous arrête alors vous avez
entendu on essaie que vous contrôliez
vraiment l'intention vous mettiez métier
d'attention avec eux ça ne dérape pas
matin très bon sauf le on souffre allez
à la boulange cheveux reid a jeté du du
du 1
il y a une une queue il ya dix personnes
qui attendent le mot pain ne trace pas
c'est la situation d'urgence
on ne naît pas bègue on le devient en
général vers 3 ou 6 ans quand on
commence à communiquer une personnalité
psychologique fragile un environnement
familial stressant bien souvent il n'en
faut pas plus pour bégayer
est-ce qu'on guérit du bégaiement oui à
coup sûr au moins pour l'enfant tout le
monde est d'accord d'une barge
spontanément sur cinq enfants bel 4 ne
le resteront pas quoi qu'il arrive
contrainte qu'on ne traite pas dans le
problème c'est de s'occuper de celui ci
risque de rester pour cela encore
faut-il savoir où s'adresser
tant est grand le nombre des méthodes
thérapeutiques une association s'est
créée aux entretiens de bichat elle a
présenté ses objectifs guider les
patients entreprendre en fin d étude
sérieuse sur le bégaiement et surtout
surtout donner la parole aux bugs
les pilotes du feuilleton maradona la
star retrouve un club en espagne séville
après n'est écartée des terrains de
football depuis des mois condamné pour
trafic de drogue est violemment contesté
par les italiens diego la star vault
encore une belle petite fortune plus de
37 millions de francs
c'est le prix de la transaction alain
dorgans le marchandage de maradona a
pris fin c'est à l'issue de cette
réunion de médiation convoqué à zurich
par la fédération internationale que
diego maradona pourra rejouer au
football sous les couleurs du fc séville
le président du sc naples auquel
appartient pour un an encore maradona
jusque-là intransigeant s'est montré
conciliant à l'égard du fc séville
révisant à la baisse le montant du
transfert initialement prévu à 42
millions 5 de francs
finalement l'accord du transfert a été
conclu sur la base de 37 millions 5
le contrat de maradona d'un an
renouvelable au fc séville est assortie
de la condition que le joueur argentin
ne pourra être transférée vers un autre
club italien pendant deux ans après 15
mois de suspension pour usage de cocaïne
et un bras de fer de trois mois avec
naples son ancien club
diego maradona pourra renouer avec le
football de haut niveau
pour carlos bilardo son entraîneur a
sévi qui lui déjà sur sa coupe en
sélection nationale
maradona revient au football par amour
du jeu et probablement pour disputer le
mondial 1994 aux états unis ma joie est
immense puisque ça fait deux ans que je
n'ai pas joué mais bon il faut vraiment
que je sois au mieux de mes possibilités
il faudra que je retrouve toutes mes
capacités physiques pour contrecarrer
mes adversaires
diego maradona s'affranchir at il de la
pression qui se manifestera sans cesse à
l'andalousie un premier élément de
réponse le 28 septembre à séville où
maradona discutera un match amical face
au bayern de munich
enfin le cinéma avec la sortie demain de
lune de fiel de roman polanski lune de
fiel adapté du roman de pascal bruckner
et roman qui avait fait scandale lors de
sa parution en 80 et polanski a
justement développer cette ambiance
ambiguë et parfois malsaine en racontant
l'histoire peu banale de deux couples à
la fiche
emmanuelle seigner peter coyote et
kristin scott thomas ce reportage de
michel vial dans le huis clos d'un
paquebot entre marseille et istanbul la
doubler trouble histoire d'une déchéance
amoureuse
le roman de pascal bruckner publia 11
ans présentaient des situations plutôt
cru voir scabreuse un récit très corsée
dans lequel s'entremêlent la perversion
et la folie de l'écrit à l'image
l'histoire à évoluer le propos se
déplacer et peut-être a perdu un peu de
son extravagance
mon propos était d'analyser une passion
intense dévorante et montrer la manière
dont une
la folie érotique pouvait se
métamorphoser en cruauté alors je crois
que polanski a trouvé dans cet univers
là quelque chose qui était en résonance
avec sa propre existence avec ceux qui
l'avaient filmé auparavant
l'impression quand même que par rapport
au lycée un petit peu édulcorée il y à
des scènes dans les livres qu'on peut
pas montrer sur les craintes pas
aujourd'hui pas maintenant il fallait
bien limiter un peu les l'excès mais il
en resterait pas mal difficile en effet
de transcrire tous les jeux pervers
auquel l'image impose forcément des
limites
reste qu'au delà des deux regards lune
de fiel témoigne de la même vision
pessimiste du monde selon laquelle tout
amour réussi porte en lui les germes de
sa propre destruction de toute façon je
ne m'attendais absolument pas être
traduit fidèlement
mais ce qui m'intéressait c'était de
voir la manière dont polanski me trahir
est je crois qu'elle trahit par pendant
ce qui s'est vraiment un destin qu'on
peut souhaiter à beaucoup d'auteurs
revenons pour terminer sur l'information
principale de ce journal les violents
orages qui ont touché le sud de la
france cet après midi trois personnes
sont mortes près d'aubenas une quatrième
est portée disparue le plan orsec a été
déclenché dans le vaucluse à
vaison-la-romaine un immeuble s'est
effondré et cinq personnes seraient
mortes sous les décombres c'est une
information de nos confrères de france 3
marseille
dans quelques secondes bien sûr la météo
complète de michel touré et la rédaction
de la 3 vous proposera bien sûr un
nouveau point complet dans soir 3 22h30
qui sera présenté ce soir par richard
tripous à 20h30 vous retrouvez sur
france 3 à tintin bien sûr et ensuite
faut pas rêver avec sylvain augier à
demain 19h bonsoir bonsoir